let's talk about Adam Jensen shall we
yeah Deus Ex mankind divided recently
supposed to come out februari this year
a blue so now it's coming out oddest
23rd five years to the day since the
deus ex human revolution I can't believe
that's been five years yeah that seems
that's troubling I agree actually hadn't
even realized it had been that long that
crazy quite a long 2011 I'd cuz it
seemed like they were dead on to make a
sequel to this game it seemed to do well
yeah it's all surprised people people
were talking about it well past the
release date to like it was still a
relevant game a while allow yeah a lot
of people seem to enjoy the only
criticism of that one if I remember
correctly was the the sort of boss
fights for sued not to be stealthy and
forced you to play a certain way that
was the hottest game was about player
agency and it's our threw it out the
window that was that's exactly right
yeah so you've played a bunch of how
much have you played scotch yeah so I
got to play it back in September and
then I got to play it again last week
and saw it different sections both times
so back in September I sought a lot of
like just dedicated story missions that
were focused on combat or stealth it was
just like straight up gameplay so what I
played more recently was like the open
world segment and a lot of the social
conversation system so I've now seen
actually a really well-rounded portrait
of the game which was really nice the
more recent stuff was like I got to
check out Prague which is sort of the
home city it's sort of like Detroit was
in human revolution you'll jump off from
there and go to other parts of the world
to do missions but that sort of seems to
be the hub area the main hub area so I
got to kind of like look around for side
quests and explore and find hidden stuff
like that so yeah new areas side quests
conversation system even saw some new
augment stuff like that cool I want to
keep this up with two people in the
child as well and act on your dwyer in
the games watch out of the twitch chat
if you have any questions and I'll be
sure to pass them on first of all I want
to ask you about Prague because I got a
real like half like to vibe off of the
gameplay when I see this cuz that was
also like set in a some sort of like
generic we don't know better Russia and
maybe or Eastern European city right
yeah and what was it like exploring
Prague how big was the open world like
what would you kind of do what was the
moment-to-moment action to see like you
ambling around and talking to people or
were you like using your stealth and
stuff like that like had actual
feel yeah so during those sections
you're free to explore your own pace
like you you there are no like time
restrictions really there are no
directives you can kind of just like
take your time between missions and
explore and do whatever you want to be
clear it's not like a fully open world
game it's not one big giant map it's
actually a bunch of discrete open areas
that are connected by a subway system so
you can kind of like explore this area
then run down into a subway station and
like pick a new destination there's a
little cutscene and it whisks you away
in your ass in the darkness area kind of
it yet it's so it's a little more like
that yeah there's some definite
half-light vibes to like to the way the
city's designed it actually for me
suffers cut from kind of the same
problem as Detroit or Shanghai in the
previous game where the city areas don't
really feel like cities too right yeah
um they're like weirdly tubular like if
you're if you're running around and like
Grand Theft Auto or something you kind
of like see an area you can run over to
it you kind of go wherever you want it
feels like a natural city ya hear your
options for where you can go are like
very limited so it ends up feeling like
a game level but that's just like that's
just me kind of wanting immersion
because as a playable game space it's
actually really impressive it's really
densely packed with like things to find
hidden areas vents terminals to hack
people interact with way more people now
than there were in the previous game
warmer when were people to talk to and
interact with many of whom give you side
quests now in the previous game there
really only a handful of side quests in
the entire game so even though as a city
it doesn't feel super believable as a
game space it seems to work really well
because there's a lot to do so I you di
are you jumping from frog den to like
diff emissions that are in like
different parts of the world from there
yeah so there was a story based mission
that occurred within Prague but then
immediately after completing that I went
to a different section of the city which
I guess is yes so technically still in
probably not in that same hub world
where I started right um so that was
still technically in Prague but it
looked very different it was like a
bombed-out train station but then after
that like sort of the final segment that
I played was in a different part of the
world entirely it was in like this ugh
this slum for augmented people called
golem city that looked very like Blade
Runner II like dystopian everything was
made out of scrap metal somehow really
eerie gold lighting throughout so
that was totally separate from the main
city and I just like got on a chopper to
get whisked away to that part of the
world wherever that happens to be so
it's still like a linear first person
totally / third person i'm guessing
experience oh yeah the narrative and
like the the main campaign is definitely
not here how did the action field and is
it familiar to human Revolution or so
too yeah it's a human revolution is it
the same sort of like cover mechanic
third person you can stealth you can
actually like did it feel all that
different because like a lot of people
to chat are pointing at the fact that
this seems like the reception that it
seems to be quite like there is much
hype going into this almost like we kind
of it feels like a known quantity does
it play a lot like the previous game it
no it definitely does I mean certain
things have been improved or fleshed out
like for example the big gameplay hook
for Adam Jensen's that his body has like
all these cybernetic enhancements which
manifests in various ways usually in
terms of like weapons or you know like
hacking abilities or stealth abilities
things like that so there are new new
augments available many of which are
allow you to play non-lethally which in
the previous game most of the augments
seemed to be combat oriented so right I
clearly heard that criticism were like
okay we're gonna try to implement new
augments that really foster these
different play styles and encourage
people to play different ways but yeah
that part of it is still very true the
game very much focuses on allowing you
to play how you want to play and a lot
of the staples of the game player there
like the switching between third person
first person when you go into cover um
the ability to like cloak and move and
like finding those hidden vents or
hacking terminals like all that stuff
plays very similarly to how it did in
the previous game and I guess the Devils
in the detail a lot of this sort of
stuff like so how did it feel to you
over the arrows you were playing that it
was at an enjoyable experience were
there levels that you played through
that you thought hey I wouldn't mind
redoing that as action or stealth or did
it feel like too familiar it was kind of
a mix i mean i think the game still
actually has some rough edges um there
are clearly a lot of really great ideas
and i'm still very optimistic about the
game i will say that the combat I never
quite got a feel for it I never really
had too much fun I feel like the game
really limits your ammo supply and her
energy supply so if you're like going
full loud you trying to kill everybody
you have to be very careful in how you
do it because you could easily run out
of resources right
or just get straight up murdered lady
just use a chainsaw and the I'm a father
yeah you Peter immediately very much not
doom and I yeah but in a way I think
that's actually kind of great like there
are so many great third person shooters
out there that if you want to just go
like bang bang shoot E whatever right
you have tons of options to that what I
think this game does really well is
giving you almost more of like a mass
effect style approach to things where
you can socialize your way through
things you can like stealth your way
through things I really prefer those
x-rays probably uh there's like a
potential love interest in the story
yeah maybe maybe not but I I didn't see
any sec there's a shower scene alright
so that that happens get to see all of
ya augmentin yeah sexy augments and like
a steamy shower then that was I know
what I dog guess no sex scenes that I
saw though but yeah they really fleshed
out the dialogue system which I am a
total sucker for like I love branching
dialogue trees like math Specter fallout
so there's a lot more of that in this
game and I feel like you have more
control over those conversations as a
player than you did before you have more
opportunities to pick dialogue options
and direct the way things are going so I
thought that was really cool so I'm
optimistic about those pillars like the
social and the stealth pillars to me or
are really exciting a really fun similar
to the previous game but still really
cool cool I'm kind of curious how you
felt about the the facial animations
like I got problems with Adam Jensen's
voice don't notice that's a personal
nitpick but looking at the facial
animations and people talking it looks
like really outdated ya know I I
definitely agree they look really wonky
and almost like out of sync and I kept
wondering if like I don't think that's
just like our video like that's how I
remember being when I was playing the
game live like just me and a constant
little TV so I don't know what the deal
is but I agree that it's it's pretty day
so I'm wondering does that sort of that
aspect like manifest itself in in other
ways like it are you noticing that this
game is pretty sound throughout or based
on just what I'm looking at with the
dialogue stuff it seems like they sort
of picked and choose what to really pay
attention to yeah I noticed that that
maybe is the case with the game at large
i would say that another good example of
that is actually the aiming which is
another reason i really don't like the
combat that much it's not a bad but I
feel like the aiming was tuned for mouse
and keyboard i was playing on a
controller so it's very 121 so when you
zoom in suddenly like the
reticles really jumpy even if the
sensitivity is way down which I tend to
turn the sensitivity up when i'm playing
shooters on a console but in this case
actually had to turn it down so that I
could aim accurately while I'm aiming
down site so I mean there's still a
month before the game is out i'm certain
there will be a day one patch because
that's what happens with every game so
it's entirely possible some of those
edges will be smooth before the game
comes out so i don't want to like fully
condemn it but i think that what you're
hitting on is accurate i think there are
some rough edges there are things in the
game that look better than other aspects
of the game right look or feel better um
so I mean tons of great ideas and I have
a lot of faith in this team because they
they really seem to know what they're
doing but yeah I mean it wasn't a
flawless demo I didn't come away going
like this was this amazing I can't wait
I'm a little more like reluctance to you
know shower with praise but we'll see
you know it's certainly not like trying
to cast aspersions on the dev team but
yeah they're working with a budget and
with a schedule of course like some
things have to fall by the wayside yeah
this is the tragedy of triple-a
development it's always like you're
managing time and budget in manpower and
just a million factors and like your
ambitions sometimes they're not going to
align with the final product or do the
best you can but yeah I was actually
doesn't pleasantly surprised my home
which they ended up raining it in for
the previous game how much they sort of
like it was a game with rough edges no
dash but it had sort of enough of a
concise vision that it was it was I can
kept me coming back anyway that's kind
of the story of deus ex as a whole
series though I don't even think it was
just the right game yeah every day of
sex game I've looked at is kind of like
yeah like there's something about it
that just doesn't feel like it's not
like they didn't get to go the finish
line all the way then everyone seems to
love these aspects of it yeah a
difficult franchise to take over as well
definitely is i mean i agree that
there's just something about the
franchise or something about it's sort
of conspiratorial world and the idea of
the augments and the fact that you
really can play combat stealth or
packing or social it really does support
all of these pillars that's pretty
unique i mean not many games can really
pull that off so I can see why for
certain people this franchise is like
just something they will always love you
know warts and all right yeah it's
interesting you say that because there
hasn't been many games which have done
that blush we have dishonored two coming
up in 2016 we have very similar and that
sort of respect and then also why
inspector working on the new system
shock
make as well which probably will be up
for a while but yeah kind of general
though send myself I'm excited for that
to exist i mean the early trailer the
new system job looks really great so if
they can make the whole game look and
feel that great then thumbs up you know
say go Deus Ex mankind divided coming
out august twenty-third scott where can
they see or a preview what's a cold son
gave all right it is on gamespot i
believe it's just called exploring
mankind divided open-world social
systems and more relatively boring title
but wonder for people like here listen
here's the stuff of the game that we
haven't made able to see yet come check
out what we actually played recently
yeah it's hard to sex off Adam Jensen
and a headline so yeah we showed us out
that I was Jensen that voice will shower
all events he has the worst voiceover
it's like it's the Batman problem right
it's like I why you're doing this but
it's a bit it's a bit like you're
forcing is so Hanny yeah that dude
sounds like in real life though which is
like the most interviews with that guy
like his voice is at he actually sounds
like this in real life it's really crazy
just saying the supporting like NPCs
like sound far more convincing than the
guy who they have he's just like smoking
two packs of Reds every day just like
it's dude Steven we've got cybernetic
lungs it's cool help me Scott yeah it's
good point you and beauty of the futures
of smoke aches a future yeah okay let's
wrap up there Scott thank you so much
for coming on absolutely I really
appreciate it
you